okay so I I'm gonna give you my opinion
and I you can comment on it I think it's
99.999 the woman's fault if she gets
pregnant why do you think that because
we are in control of sex
we won there's a million forms of birth
control
two
you could you can
you get to pick who you sleep with yep
and three
there's condoms and four you can even
get an abortion
so I think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's
I think that men out here just shooting
up in random girls are dumb okay I think
you guys are stupid
so do you think so but but I would say
that the responsibility is mostly on the
woman rather than the guy so I I don't
disagree that culturally so
there is more power in the woman in
regards to getting pregnant
but to say that men are only responsible
for one percent of that I disagree I
would say because it does take two to
tango because here's the thing right it
is true that most men would have sex
with anything yeah
but they're the small percentage of men
who maybe have a lot of options wouldn't
they exercise
discipline especially if their time is
money right but even even if let's say
they were a condom right what happened
to Drake
hahaha
that doesn't count it does count that
happens to really successful men all the
time no no what I mean it's like that's
not that's completely on her that's not
even one person but that's what I'm
saying like even if a guy wears a condom
a girl can take it it's true yeah that's
that's true that's an exception that's
that's not his fault but I would I would
say if she got pregnant from that that's
that's not 99 her that's 100 her yeah
that's none of him yeah I'm saying if it
was if you're gonna oh yeah yeah
um [ __ ] You Drake
no but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah she's
making that text but he's making it okay
but let's say she does who is the who is
the choice to take the Plan B pill
no oh no who has the power to yeah she
does she that's why who has the power to
get an abortion it is her yeah it's true
does the man have any say in that I
agree so that's why I say it's it's her
own fault you Coulda you could okay
let's say let's say one you can track
your cycle there's only like five days
in a month or whatever that you're
really likely to get pregnant I know it
can happen outside of that yeah okay but
you can track your cycle that doesn't
work what can you do a condom okay if
that doesn't work you can get a Plan B
pill if that doesn't work next time
around getting IUD so if that doesn't
work no no I'm not done okay if that
doesn't work and you get pregnant you
can go get an abortion the men have no
say in this none I know so so like
that's why I said culturally so I don't
understand how these girls are saying oh
it just happened what do you mean it
just happened that I agree that City
like any girls just like oh my gosh it
just happened she got pregnant like you
you played that part yeah here's my
question to you right so there's like
over 40 forms of birth control for women
yeah if it were reversed there was over
40 forms of birth control for men yeah
but it was still obviously women who
choose who have sex with so I'm saying
the intersexual Dynamics yes yeah yeah
but in terms of culturally it is men who
has the birth control Power not women
would that then change your position
who's responsible and who's responsible
no because at the end of the day women
men have no say in abortion if you get a
girl pregnant and you're crying to her
and saying I don't want you to get that
abortion there ain't [ __ ] there ain't
[ __ ] you can do you can't save that kid
and so at the end of the day A woman
can't have a child that they don't want
to have
so I fully agree with that I feel like
I'm fully like that's my personal like
if I ever got pregnant so I am sexually
active I'm not on contraception but I
tell men straight away I'm like come in
me don't come on me and I'm like but I
know if that if that happens I'm like
well it's my responsibility to be like
girl you're what what are you doing
[Music]
STD STD that ruins your life I've
already had chlamydia I got committee
don't do this to yourself
you clearly did it
would have been that response I was 18
it was the second guy I ever slept with
in my life we were friends we were XYZ
and then I get that text being like hey
and I was like hey it's like oh so
um I uh do you wear a condom uh no okay
[Applause]
a lot of people if you don't know
chlamydia is passed just through contact
they don't need to come inside you so
even if they've got chlamydia on their
hands
what would reduce your odds I mean to
that point at that point I was a very
different human being but I'm like oh I
had to come but you're not because
you're doing the same thing now well no
no because everyone I make sure that
everyone also do you make them get
tested and make them yeah really we
don't say clean either so I was an ex
sexual health professional we don't say
clean we say SCD free because obviously
the opposite of clean is dirty and we
don't we don't perpetuate that like
stigma so I'll say like I I literally
will say to people and be like hey I'll
tell them I'm like I'm not on
contraception but I I get tested very
regularly wait wait you're not wait
you're not on birth control
no and that is because you know I can't
and that is because because it [ __ ] it
[ __ ] up my hair [ __ ] up my body it
[ __ ] up everything you know what [ __ ]
up your body a baby
but I'm responsible for that I'm
responsible for that what income no no
but what I'm saying is abortion but what
I'm saying is you know what else [ __ ]
up your body
abortion yeah yeah and your mental
health this is what we're talking about
it's responsibility is that I'm like if
that happened so I tell men and they're
like oh pull up method or or I'm like
okay like if you do you want to use a
condom like cool like I'm like yeah I'd
rather they did but if I ever got
pregnant I wouldn't be like well it's
your fault I'd be like no this is all
okay but this is like point in case
where women are using abortion as a form
of birth control instead of something
that should be used in an emergency oh
no no so like fortunately that's it I'm
27 I've like had a lot of oh
was like yeah um but that's it I'm like
yeah we will either I'll tell men and so
a lot of men a lot of men that I sleep
with actually to be fair most of them
are like well I'm either not going to
come on you or I'm gonna wear a condom
or I'm like you're just not gonna finish
like okay okay we'll finish in a another
way
um and if a guy is like I'm still gonna
try and finish decide you I'm like no
you're not because like I'll call you
Daddy but I don't want to make you a
daddy like that's literally like
I will say that's a man all the time I
just want to clarify some understanding
so right now you're in the streets right
yeah yeah yeah your street you're
streeting you know street but even that
is that is a judgment on women to be
like hey casual sex is not okay for
women I didn't say if it was okay for me
what I'm what I'm what I'm judging you
for I'm gonna be honest yeah yeah it's
just it's just like this is so
irresponsible because if I'm
understanding it right okay so so you're
sleeping with these guys you don't you
don't know
okay you date them you date them and
you're not on birth control and you have
them finishing you no they don't finish
me no no definitely not come on no no no
the opposite the opposite oh oh no no
[ __ ] there's like oh my God I love it I
was gonna correct her but I wanted to
see how far this would go
oh no okay no no that's my bad oh no
that's the love here's to honor if you
can't come in here come on her I tell
him straight away straight away I'm like
do not finish inside me and that's why I
say I'm like I will call you Daddy do
you want to be a daddy they all go no no
you're only you don't have them wear
condoms though your only form of is pull
out oh no no like they can wear a condom
but then then it's on the guy that
they're like well I don't want to do and
I'm like you get to pick so like like do
you do you make them wear a condo I
don't make them if they don't want to
okay but then I I have the conversation
with them I'm like look you've got
choices either you don't finish you wear
a condom okay or you pull out but I'm
well aware that if they don't if they
don't pull out in time I'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I get tested very regularly that's it
except sexual health professional sexual
health is the one part of our health
that we are fully responsible for we are
fully responsible for getting tested we
are fully responsible I agree with you I
agree
I do think as an individual as a woman
if if I was to get pregnant from my
Reckless Behavior I'd be like it's not
on you it's on me I have taken that risk
yeah and I was like I'll take that risk
but because I am very comfortable with
the idea of I know the water is not nice
yeah I'm not here like if I get pregnant
I have an abortion I'm like you know
what if I like you don't get in a car
thinking I'm gonna be in a car accident
but you know full well every time you
get in a car or you get on a plane yeah
like there is a low-key chance that this
could not end well for me it's just